arbeitslosigkeit das kann aber muss
keine folge von digitalisierung seien
negativ sind die folgen ja nur wenn man
digitalisierung fallschirm kurzfristig
plan statt sie nachhaltig zu realisieren
mit oder ohne roboter
es gibt also wenigstens eine kleine
hoffnung dass sich ausnahmsweise mal
unsere gemeinsame natürliche dummheit
als intelligent und klug erweist um gut
mit digitalisierung und künstliche
intelligenz um zu gehen allerdings hat
der un-bericht diese woche leider
gezeigt dass unsere natürliche dummheit
im umgang mit der natur und der
artenvielfalt meist überwiegt einen
schönen guten abend meine damen und
herren bei scobel
wir befassen uns heute mit einem thema
das entscheidend unsere zukunft prägen
und beeinflussen wird
es geht um lernfähiger algorithmen und
robotersysteme von denen wir
möglicherweise eines tages sagen müssen
ihr roboter habt bewusstsein
genau daran arbeiten zurzeit viele
wissenschaftlerinnen fieberhaft auf den
punkt gebracht lautet die frage unserer
sendung heute so angenommen man findet
heraus was die eckdaten von bewusstsein
sind und was bewusstsein ausmacht und
weiter angenommen man hat so etwas wie
eine minimale bauanleitung weiß also was
man mindestens braucht damit so etwas
wie bewusstsein entstehen und ein system
bewusstseins fähig werden kann könnten
wir dann ein solches system bauen
kurzum ist künstliches bewusstsein
möglich
[Musik]
ki hat ein enormes potenzial in der
robotik mit hilfe von forschern führen
heute automaten tätigkeiten aus die
früher menschen per hand vollzogen alles
ist programmiert der arbeiter ist
überflüssig jedoch lernen aus einsicht
kann ein roboter noch nicht doch der
traum von fühlenden denkenden maschinen
steht hoch im kurs
bislang sind roboter schlechte kopien
der natur aber die digitalen
schnittstellen zwischen umwelt
organischen lebensformen und
technologien nehmen zu nicht zuletzt
durch gigantische investitionen die
evolution der lebewesen auf der erde ist
einige milliarden jahre alt die
geschichte der ki nur 60 jahre
wissenschaftler vermuten dass sich
jährlich die datenmengen die wir
produzieren verdoppeln
damit erhöhen sich die chancen autonome
informations verarbeitende systeme zu
entwickeln
nach vorstellung einiger visionäre
könnte daran gearbeitet werden
einfachste bewusstsein strukturen nach
dem masterplan des gehirns zu bauen und
den künstlichen systemen zu
implementieren
als vorbilder dienen oft biologische
systeme aber ab welcher
entwicklungsstufe spricht man von
intelligenten verhalten
wie sich das bewusstsein durch die
evolution entwickelte dafür gibt es
bislang keine umfassende theoretische
erklärung
wie können minimale bedingungen für
biologische systeme aussehen
warum verhalten sich zum beispiel
hirnlose quallen intelligent bleibt
künstliche intelligenz die alle nuancen
der sinneswahrnehmung des fühlens des
denkens simulieren kann nur eine vision
soweit also die vision systeme mit
künstlichen brust sein zu bauen was
voraussetzt dass wir wissen was
bewusstsein ist handelt sich also um
reine science fiction darüber werden wir
gleich sprechen und ich begrüße herzlich
martin korte ist biologe arbeitete unter
anderem am max planck institut für
hirnforschung in frankfurt und forscht
heute als professor für zelluläre
neurobiologie an der tu braunschweig und
er sagt bewusstsein wird einem
zugeschrieben von anderen und ich sehe
in absehbarer zeit nicht dass wir
roboter einem dem menschlichen gehirn
vergleichbares bewusstsein im sinne von
selbstbewusstsein zu schreiben werden
dann begrüßt sich thomas metzinger er
ist philosoph und professor für
theoretische philosophie schwerpunkt
neuro philosophie an der universität
eine universität mainz und fellow am
frankfurt institute for advanced studies
fias und sagt künstliches bewusstsein
ist momentan extrem unwahrscheinlich
aber ein wichtiges problem für die ki
ethik wir sollten es nicht einmal
riskieren bevor wir wissen was wir da
genau tun und ich begrüße raul rojas es
professor für informatik an der freien
universität berlin wo er vor allem im
bereich robotik und neuronale netze
forscht er experimentiert unter anderem
auf dem gebiet des autonomen fahrens und
sagt roboter werden echtes bewusstsein
nie haben und brauchen es auch nicht
herzlich willkommen
es gibt einfache lebewesen die quallen
die nahezu hundertprozentig aus wasser
bestehen damit definitiv kein gehirn
haben aber so etwas wie aktive
entscheidungen und klare autonome
verhaltenssteuerung auszuführen in der
lage sind vielleicht sind wir beim
nachdenken über die minimal bedingungen
von bewusstsein also zu sehr auf uns
also den stamm der wirbel und säugetiere
und ihre gehirne fixiert richtig und
sinnvoll an dieser frage richtung ist
jedoch sich zuerst mit der evolution von
leben zu befassen um zu verstehen wie
bewusstsein überhaupt entstehen konnte
am ende stellt die biologische evolution
die auch die grundlage für künstliche
bewusste systeme da nämlich für die die
wir selber entwerfen
alles leben auf unserem planeten geht
auf einen evolutionären prozess zurück
und der beginnt vermutlich im meer aus
organischen verbindungen formen sich
dort zunächst zell ähnliche strukturen
dann einzeller später komplexeren
lebewesen für ungefähr 300 bis 400
millionen jahren bevölkern nur fische
die ozeane und flüsse sie sind die
ersten lebewesen mit skelett die ersten
amphibien entstehen vor 50 bis 100
millionen jahren danach die reptilien
primaten breiten sich aus die gattung
homo erscheint vor zweieinhalb millionen
jahren auf der erde aus ihr entwickelt
sich vor 300.000 jahren der heutige homo
sapiens
die biologische evolution ist ein
ständiger kampf ums überleben
faktoren wie mutation und selektion
bescheren den lebewesen einen vor oder
nachteil in diesem kampf genetische
vielfalt hilft dabei unterschiedliche
lebensformen auszubilden und zu
optimieren
da sich alle arten aus einem gemeinsamen
urahn entwickelt haben trägt jedes
lebewesen heute diese
entwicklungsgeschichte in sich auch beim
menschen sind spuren und reste dieses
erbes im körper aufbewahrt in der form
der knochen der struktur der dna in
nervengeflecht und gehirn
das veranlasst bereits charles darwin zu
der annahme dass sich mensch und tier
nicht nur in anatomische hinsicht
gleichen sondern auch in emotionen und
verhaltensweisen
eine große rolle spielt hierbei die
weitergabe von wissen menschenaffen
vermitteln fähigkeiten weiter und
erlernen sie durch nachahmung doch
besitzen tiere tatsächlich so was wie
bewusstsein bewusstsein wurde bisher mit
bewussten handeln und selbstbewusstsein
gleichgestellt lange zeit scheint das
nur dem menschen vorbehalten
tiere hält man dagegen für geistlos bis
wissenschaftler bei einigen arten den
sogenannten spiegel test machen um zu
überprüfen ob sich die tiere in einem
spiegel selbst erkennen denn dies lässt
darauf schließen ob sie über eine
selbstwahrnehmung verfügen tatsächlich
tun sie das dies gilt offenbar vor allem
für arten wie der mensch komplexe
soziale strukturen aufweisen
auch finden verhaltensforscher heraus
dass manche tiere zu emotionen fähig
sind die denen des menschen gleichen
freude trauer angst und wut gehört
jedoch zu den mentalen oder psychischen
kompetenzen von tieren auch das denken
bereits früher untersuchungen zeigen
menschenaffen können wie der mensch
werkzeuge herstellen und nutzen auch
kleinere mengen vergleichen und sie
verfügen somit über kognition und
intelligenz
sie können zielgerecht handeln und zum
teil die absichten ihrer art genossen
lesen und setzten somit ihrer eigenen
repräsentationen also ihre gedanken über
die welt miteinander in verbindung
ähnlich wie die menschen es tun sind es
also nur graduelle unterschiede die
mensch und tier voneinander
unterscheiden
tatsächlich gibt es einfache organismen
wie schleimpilze eine art riesen amöbe
die ohne gehirn lernen und komplexe
entscheidungen treffen also probleme
lösen können
denn ein schleimpilz kann artgenossen in
seiner umgebung aufspüren wenn sich zwei
genetisch identische schleimpilze
begegnen verschmelzen sie miteinander zu
einem einzigen großen organismus und das
hat vorteile sie können sich schneller
bewegen und nahrung finden
sie besitzen also eine art
schwarmintelligenz
darüber hinaus können schleimpilze
lernen schädliche substanzen zu
ignorieren und sich noch viel später an
ihr erlerntes verhalten erinnern
handelt es sich hierbei bereits um
kombination entsteht intelligentes
verhalten also nicht nur durch neuronen
und gehirn
sie haben alle geschmunzelt jetzt also
muss sich die frage stellen ob
schleimpilze kognition haben wenn man
das neurowissenschaftler fragt natürlich
nicht es sind auch die entscheidungen
die sie treffen sind jetzt auch nicht
wirklich komplex sind im grunde
interaktion auf der oberfläche der der
der einzelnen schleimpilze die entweder
zueinander passen oder nicht passen und
das ist an genetischen repertoire und
wir reden eigentlich immer dann von
intelligenz wenn man in einer neuen
situation zu einer neuen art von lösung
kommt als individuum und nicht stereotyp
durch evolutiven prozesse
vorprogrammiert was aber nicht heißt man
mit seiner menschlichen intelligenz
darauf schaut dass man bewundert so war
es für lösungen ganze spezies eben
kommen können
durch die ganzen evolutiven prozesse die
dahinter stehen was mich und da könnten
wir sicher jetzt eine ganze sendung
darüber machen zu tieren bringt ein
bisschen anders gebaut sind also
zumindest zumindest was ihr nervensystem
angeht wie wir
tintenfische zum beispiel sind wir
möglicherweise wenn wir diese frage nach
bewusstsein stellen viel zu sehr fixiert
auf uns als säugetiere und unserem
gehirn und das bewusstsein an sowas
gebunden sein muss wie unser gehirn denn
das tintenfisch gehirn funktioniert ein
bisschen anders als unsere sodass der
vögel auch das für also dass bei
tintenfischen insbesondere es völlig
anders aufgebaut weil sie eben nicht nur
ein gehirn haben sondern weil das gehirn
dieser tiere auf fünf verschiedene
bereiche verteilt in ihren verschiedenen
stellen des körpers legen also das
fordert uns ganz besonders heraus aber
ich möchte gleich noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass wir aufpassen dass man
nicht die begriffe intelligenz und
bewusstsein miteinander vereinen recht
das eine kann durchaus ohne das andere
existieren sag ich mal was wir ja
eigentlich meinen ist das insbesondere
tintenfische in der lage sind sich zum
beispiel aus gefängnissen zu befreien
indem sie sich kleine werkzeuge bauen
die brauchen sich dietrich
sie können eine ganze reihe von
komplexen sequenz lern ereignissen
erwerben was zum beispiel womit mäuse
sich viel schwerer tun
sie können menschen wiedererkennen sie
können sich selber wieder erkennen also
da gibt es eine reihe von sachen die die
tatsächlich überraschend sind und die
vor allen dingen darauf hinweisen dass
man aufpassen muss es ist nicht die
neuronale struktur der gehirne die
bestimmt wie intelligent eingespielt es
ist bei uns zum beispiel die homo
sapiens hat auf die entwicklung der
großhirnrinde gesetzt bei den raben
artigen vögeln sind es eigentlich eher
strukturen die bei uns unterhalb der
großhirnrinde sind die alles andere
überwuchert haben und es sind tiere die
sehr intelligente entscheidungen treffen
können die auch werkzeuge benutzen
können die in sozialen verbänden agieren
manchmal auch jagen dann haben wir eben
schon die genannten tintenfische die
eben wiederum eine ganz andere
gehirnstruktur haben und eben auch unter
bestimmten umständen zu verhaltensweisen
kommen denen zumindest ein komplexer
algorithmus zugrunde liegt ja ich wurde
dass er in die problematik werde wieder
viel vor intelligenz aber ich denke es
ist ein kontinuum mehrmals fast immer
wieder die intelligenz
gedacht das heißt es gibt die
menschliche intelligenz und das ist die
intelligenz aber es gibt ein ganzes
kontinuum von 0 bis 1 2 du nicht mal so
zwischen das was ein bakterium kann und
dass er ein mensch gang und dazwischen
gibt es alle generierung alle stufen und
manchmal so etwas wie fassen übergang in
der physik wo wir über schmerz empfinden
würden
bei bestimmten themen oder eigenen
erkennung und die wahrnehmung der
situation in der welt und dann am ende
natürlich die menschliche intelligenz
aber es ist ein kontinuum das ist was
man modellieren nicht ich denke dass das
für die für die intelligenz genau die
richtige gang gehen zwar ist deswegen
habe ich das abgetrennt vom bewusstsein
weil es kann sein dass wenn man unsere
kultur vergleich die wir als menschen
haben mit denen was passt ihre in der
lage sind zu leisten da sehe ich nicht
ein gradueller unterschied da sehe ich
einen qualitativen unterschied wir
teilen 98,5 prozent unserer dna mit
schimpansen aber unsere leben und die
sind weitergabe von informationen die
reichhaltigkeit von sprache könnte nicht
unterschiedlicher sein als zwischen zwei
spiels ist die genetisch so ähnlich sind
und hier könnte sein dass
selbstbewusstsein was entsteht durch ein
sprachliches miteinander durch einen
kulturellen austausch einen wagenheber
effekt für das bewusstsein hatte um dann
wiederum auch für intelligenz so dass in
diesem kontinuum wie sie es beschrieben
haben an verschiedenen intelligenzen der
menschen doch dann nach oben hin in
anführungsstrichen doch weit hinaus
schießt aber nicht als einzelner mensch
sondern daneben als gruppe muss man
kognitive komplexität und
lebensfähigkeit bewusstsein wirklich
auseinander halten also sehr überspitzt
gesagt könnte es sehr dumme tiere geben
die tief empfindungsfähigkeit leiden
können und schmerzen empfinden können
und wir haben auch roboter die sich
selbst im spiegel erkennen können von
denen niemand annimmt dass die
subjektive erlebnisse haben also ich
finde eine sache kann man schon sagen
für biosysteme wenn alle eigenschaften
des nervensystems feststehen dann stehen
auch alle bewusstseins eigenschaften
fest ob es da eine reduzierung geben
kann das ist erstmal noch eine ganz
andere frage
die wichtige frage ist eigentlich die
ist eben schon angeklungen was sind die
interessanten eigenschaften des gehirns
wenn es uns um subjektive erleben geht
ist dass die architektur sind es ganz
bestimmte ebenen in der
informationsverarbeitung und das wissen
wir einfach nicht also beim tintenfisch
könnte man sich analog fragen der armen
beim tinten bei den tintenfischen eine
gewisse autonomie hat erlebt der sich
eigentlich selber oder braucht es
sozusagen den ganzen tintenfisch damit
das system sich oder den arm erlebt
einfach einfacher formuliert ist in
ihren augen bewusstsein und
selbstbewusstsein eigentlich dasselbe
oder ist es ist der häufigste fehler
also das ist der häufig des häufigste
missverständnis dass leute denken dass
etwas bewusstsein hat bedeutet
automatisch dass es ein ich gefühl hat
wir kennen ja viele zustände sagen wir
mal in der meditation nach einnahme von
halluzinogenen aber auch bei der
personalisierung störungen der
psychiatrie in dem es nicht zentriertes
bewusstsein bewusstsein ohne
selbstbewusstsein lebt und auf der
anderen seite gibt es künstliche systeme
von denen wir annehmen dass sie kein
bewusstsein haben die ein starkes selbst
modell haben die im körper kontrollieren
können sehr intelligent und autonom wie
roboter und es gibt auch menschen
schlafwandler zum beispiel oder mit bei
epileptischen absenzen motorischen
automatismen die sehr komplexe
körperkontrolle auf basis eines inneren
bildes von sich selbst durchführen und
niemand würde denken dass da etwas
erlebt wird also wenn wir beide
unterscheiden müssen wie wie glauben sie
hängen die zusammen bewusstsein und
selbstbewusstsein oder gibts dann
notwendigen zusammenhang vielleicht
haben wir ja gar kein bewusstsein wir
denken nur wir hätten
ja aber da würde man natürlich die
eigene erfahrung gegensätzen und eben
sagen jetzt erst zählt natürlich auch
meine in der zeit in der in der tat
meine innenperspektive die ich mich
erlebe und das würde man sich natürlich
ungern absprechen lassen ich mich
richtig erinnere hat das auch eines der
argumente die kante immer gemacht hat
aber ich möchte mal auf den punkt von
eben zurückkommen denn sie gesagt haben
mit dem arm ob er bewusstsein hat uns
selbstbewusstsein weil das führt zu
einer ganz paradoxen situation als
neurowissenschaftler möchte man das
natürlich gerne neuronale erklären dann
fängt man mit der frage wie viele
nervenzellen braucht man denn bis
irgendeine art von bewusstsein vorhanden
ist und man sieht dass man mit der frage
nicht weiter kommt eine nervenzelle
nicht 1000 nicht die millionen nicht
es ist offensichtlich ein ganz komplexes
zusammenspiel und vielleicht ist es
sogar mehr als ein zusammenspiel
vielleicht ist es auch ein zusammenspiel
zwischen verschiedenen gehirnen so dass
ich niemals ein teil eines gehirns oder
eines abends eines tieres sechs ihren
kann und wer werde darin irgendwie den
geist in der flasche finden sondern
vielleicht ist es etwas was was in einer
sozietät von gehirnen erst sich sich
entwickelt und entsteht und damit wäre
es wäre bewusstsein
egal in welcher form immer auch eine
form von sozialer interaktion und von
kultur die er durchaus auch bei tieren
vorhanden sein kann es gibt auch
tierische kulturen aber ich brauche
immer den anderen gegenüber und selbst
also wenn man sozusagen ganz
physiologisch sieht könnte man sagen
bewusstsein ist ein beziehungs geschehen
also zwischen verschiedenen zentren oder
das ist natürlich politisch korrekt
unterjubeln als auch immer und es stimmt
auch dass das jetzt gar nicht politisch
gilt auch dass ganz viele teile die
interessanten teile des menschlichen
bewusstseins auch sozial konstituiert
sind ja und nicht nur im gehirn aber es
gibt bewusstes erleben zum beispiel auch
im traum
ja wenn der körper gelähmt ist und
abgekoppelt er also ich glaube man kann
nicht alles durch gesellschaftliche
konstitution endlich meinte auch
beziehungen im sinne von der relation
zwischen modulen also gar nicht habe da
ich habe das gar nicht gemeint jetzt im
sinne von sozialer beziehung zu ja ich
möchte ich etwas eigentlich ich sage mal
und wie wir locken nehme mir das nicht
nicht ab das insekten kleine roboter
sind in dem sinne was ist modular
aufgebaut sind
eine eine fliege zum beispiel wenn man
eine fliege nimmt um die die füße den
kontakt zum boden verlieren fängt die
fangen die die fängt dieser fläche zu
flattern versuch so fliegen wie es
eigentlich die situation immer ist man
den kontakt zum boden ich kann ist ja
wenn die diese fliege unterwegs ist dass
die richtung wird bestimmt oder den
optischen fluss durch die bewegung von
den bänden links und rechts und das in
alle reflexe wenn diese insekten
eingebaut sind und diese dieser
zusammenspiel von zehn einfachen
reflexen überzeugt etwas das wir als
sauste entstehende als intelligenz
betrachten und das ist der trick dass
wir auch in der robotik verwenden immer
klein oder flex in den ortsteilen zu
wollen und die menschen die das er im
glauben es ist eine fantastische
leistung von den roboter und eigentlich
ist es eine einfache vernetzung von
efaflex das war scheint mir übrigens
wenn ich das sagen darf das scheint mir
ein ganz tiefes problem zu sein
nämlich die balance zwischen modulares
muss und hole es muss also in der
philosophie gibt es ja dieses klassische
alte problem der einheit des
bewusstseins und eine leistung die
bewusste systeme erbringen ist um
globale integration
eines weltmodell auf der anderen seite
gibt es diese vielen kleinen module und
irgendwie habe ich das gefühl sowohl
intelligenz als auch bewusst sein
könnten mit der richtigen balance
zwischen hole is muss und modulares muss
zu tun haben da würde ich gerne mal von
den fachleuten was drüber hören
ich denke dass unser gehirn vollständig
modularisiert ist ich beschäftige mich
unter den mit autonomes fahren
jeder weiß wir können nach hause fahren
und nicht daran denken das ist das
problem eigentlich für heutige auf
neufahrzeuge wenn man so ein roboter
kauft und da wird aber den roboter
überwachen muss ich war selber nicht und
ich kommen und wenn ich dann gern weiß
ich nicht wie ich angekommen und ich
glaube dass wir auch in unserem gehirn
solcher module vertriebsstrukturen kann
die parallel zueinander natürlich was
die meinen kommunikation aber auch und
so aber ohne kommunikation miteinander
arbeiten ich glaube trotzdem dass wir
der thomas metzinger das sagt dass es
beides ist mal ein beispiel man würde
erwarten wenn es modular aufgebaut ist
das gehirn strukturen die besonders
stark trainiert werden auch erwachsen
als andere strukturen das stimmt zum
beispiel auch zumindest vor der
erfindung der navigationsgeräte verloren
nathan sie fahren da ist der
programmpunkt größer weil das eben eine
gehirnstruktur ist wohnraum karte
abgelegt ist die von ron dennis
besonders kompliziert ist dort sind
diese gedächtnis informationen abgelegt
und ich habe ein gedächtnis weltmeister
anschaue da hat man sich auch die gegner
angeschaut die sich ja strategien
ausgedacht haben wie sie sich besonders
viel merken können sehe ich dass der pro
campus nichts größer ist was man
erwarten würde weil diese riesige
datenmengen speichern können sondern da
sind dass die netzwerke von den
gehirnarealen vor allen dingen von kurz
zum langzeitgedächtnis die verändert
wurden das heißt wir haben hier man
könnte es eine meta-ebene nennen man
könnte es aber für das gedächtnis auch
juristische ebene nennen die sich
verändert hat in ihrem verwaltungs
eigenschaften und erst durch die
veränderung dieser verschaltung
eigenschaften kommen diese wahnsinnigen
leistungen zusammen die diese gedächtnis
weltmeister zustande bringen können ohne
dass einzelne module gewachsen sind
ich will immer ganz kurz nachfrage
braucht man ihrer meinung nach um so was
wie bewusstsein zu haben eine
integration dieser dieser module also
das wird ja das wird ja immer behauptet
dass er also sowas wie selbst erleben
erst dann stattfindet wenn ich sagen wir
mal meinen hören mein mann sehen mein
gefühl mit so etwas wie mein überhaupt
verbinden kann dann erst gar nicht sagen
ich erlebe subjektiv die welt ist das
notwendig in ihren augen schwer zu sagen
ich muss sagen dass ich darauf die an
die antwort nicht weiß es gibt
verschiedene theorien dazu einige sagen
dass der spracherwerb ganz entscheidend
ist weil ich nur über die die den
abstrakt grad der sprache die distanz
aufbauen kann
ich kann also wieder in der er mit einem
inneren sprechen mit mir selber eben
reden kann mich dabei da mal beobachten
was mich dass skeptisch werden lässt es
gibt ja auch qualitäts empfindungen in
sinnesinformationen wo ich würde ich
schmerzen habe
zahnschmerzen oder wenn ich eine
besonders schöne farbe an einer blume
sehe dabei etwas empfinde
da weiß ich nicht ob ich diesen
zentralen sprachlich und integratoren
rauche intuitiv würde ich sagen da
brauche ich das nicht da scheint es also
auch noch andere möglichkeiten zu geben
so etwas wie bewusstsein in dem fall
nennt man das quali empfindungen quasi
herzustellen
andere wiederum sagen ich brauche nicht
nur unbedingt die sprache ich brauche
das was wir als arbeitsgedächtnis
bezeichnen und zwar im stirnlappen
gelegen eine ansammlung von hier in
gebieten die quasi in der repräsentation
dessen darstellen was im gehirn vor sich
geht oder ein raum darstellen indem das
repräsentiert werden kann und das was in
der umgebung passiert und hier einen für
ein abgleich sorgen und damit eben
sicher stellen welche informationen
besonders stark verarbeitet werden aber
gleichzeitig auch in enns mal so einen
blick ins gehirn haben wir eben auch zu
schauen welche prozesse dabei ablaufen
das würde dann so etwas wie wie einig
simulieren gleichzeitig gibt es eben
auch kritik an diesen an diesen modellen
wie man sich denken kann und ich muss
sagen ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
weiß nicht was da die antwort ist ja
vielen dank es ist überraschend aber bis
heute wir waren schon mal den punkt gibt
es keine klare definition von
intelligenz und noch schlechter steht es
um eine klare eindeutige definition von
dem was wir nun genau unter
muss sein verstehen wollen entsprechend
unterschiedlich fallen auch die
erklärung für die bandbreite von
phänomenen aus die wir als bewusstes
erleben bezeichnen artikel mainz also
künstlicher geist oder künstliches
bewusstsein im plural hieß ein buch aus
den neunziger jahren in dem ich zur
vorbereitung der sendung wieder wieder
gelesen habe und mir fiel dabei sehr
deutlich auf dass ich in all den jahren
zwar technisch ungeheuer viel verändert
hat vor allem mit blick auf den erfolg
des maschinen lernst was sich jedoch
überhaupt nicht verändert hat und das
finde ich erstaunlich das ist die
ratlosigkeit in bezug auf zentrale
fragen die eine längere geschichte haben
passiert sehen wenn heute auto
selbstständig fahren oder komplexe
aufgaben in industriellen prozessen von
robotern erledigt werden dann ist
künstliche intelligenz im spiel
entwickelt sich rasant
ihre anfänge aber liegen jahrzehnte
zurück
einer der wichtigsten visionäre ist der
britische mathematiker alan turing in
seinem berühmten artikel computing
machinery and intelligence entwirft er
einen test ein menschlicher fragesteller
kommuniziert ohne sicht und für kontakt
mit zwei ihm unbekannten
gesprächspartner
ein gesprächspartner ist ein mensch der
andere eine maschine
wenn der fragesteller nicht sagen kann
welche gesprächspartner die maschine ist
hat die maschine den test bestanden und
ist intelligent nur zwei jahre nach
jones tod treffen sich führende us
wissenschaftler für ein
forschungsprojekt an dortmunds college
in new hampshire ihre vision
selbstlernende maschinen lösen aufgaben
für die menschliche intelligenz
vorausgesetzt wird
hier wird der begriff artificial
intelligence künstliche intelligenz
geprägt und ein neues akademisches
fachgebiet entsteht
1960 entwickelt der amerikanische
psychologe und informatiker rosenblatt
gemeinsam mit einigen arbeitskollegen
den ersten lernfähigen computer die
maschine lernt auf basis eines
neuronalen netzwerkes nach dem prinzip
von versuch und irrtum der erste mobile
roboter shaky erfasst seine umgebung mit
kameras kann sich bewegen und einfache
aufgaben erledigen
er entsteht im labor für künstliche
intelligenz des stanford research
institute in den 70er jahren werden
forschungsgelder gestrichen es wird
still um die k
anfang der 80er jahre jedoch geht es
weiter auch in deutschland insbesondere
beim sprachverstehen und robotik haben
deutsche wissenschaftler erfolg eine
pionierleistung in der ki und kaum
bekannt dass autonome fahrzeug des
deutschen ernst dickmanns sein
entwickelt der wagen fährt selbständig
auf der autobahn von münchen nach
kopenhagen
[Musik]
und dann 1997 eine sensation
schachweltmeister garri kasparow muss
sich unter wettkampfbedingungen dem
rechner die blut von abm geschlagen
geben
zum ersten mal in der geschichte schlägt
ein computer einen menschen im schach
seit 2010 erlebt ki einen weltweiten
boom und durchdringt unsere alltagswelt
sprechende geräte digitale assistenten
autonome fahrzeuge und kooperative
roboter werden bestandteil unseres
lebens über internet social media und
eine vielzahl von sensoren stehen
plötzlich riesige datenmengen zur
verfügung mit ihnen und entsprechenden
algorithmen wird ki zunehmend optimiert
2016 schlägt das programm alpha go den
weltbesten profispieler ingo dem
komplexesten brettspiel in fünf spielen
verliert die künstliche intelligenz nur
ein einziges mal an fango ist der
prototyp einer neuen selbstlernenden
mustererkennung nach wie vor handelt es
sich bei den meisten anwendungen um
sogenannte schwache künstliche
intelligenz ki die auf ein gebiet
spezialisiert ist und spitzenleistungen
vollbringen kann aber eben nur auf
diesem einen gebiet von starker krahé
spricht man wenn ein computer das was er
gelernt hat auf ein anderes gebiet
übertragen kann
analog zur menschlichen intelligenz und
vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus heraus
was ist da eigentlich passiert also
neuronale netze die theorie die gibt's
seit den 40er jahren
wir hatten das auch schon mal in den
90er jahren dann ist es irgendwie
eingeschlafen jetzt im moment ein riesen
boom mit dem mit dem maschinen lernen
warum ist das so was passiert passiert
ist also wie künstliche intelligenz sich
in eine andere richtung entwickelt hat
die neurobiologie das heißt die heutige
künstliche intelligenz benutzt massive
daten passen - daten von benutzer oder
von gesichter die man gern erkennen
möchte und die algorithmics das heißt
die die methoden um diese neuronalen
netzes schnell zu trainieren
das hat sich stark entwickelt in den
letzten 20 jahren
und dazu kommt noch dass die rechner
viel schneller geworden sind wir haben
heute parallel rechner wie für
computerspiele
gebaut wurden aber die heute für diese
netze verwendet werden können und dann
das zusammenspiel von all das sehr
schneller rechner neue algorithmen zu
erfüllen muss sehr große dateien was ist
das hat dazu geführt dass seit einigen
jahren das sogenannte tiefe lernen oder
neben learning sehr in mode gekommen ist
und das ist die benutzung von einem
butterbrot das heißt wenn eine methode
massive hat der verarbeitung tod rechnen
so sagte kreft bestimmte anwendungen
dann bereit zu stellen
und das ist nicht wie das mensch sorge
brust aber das ist etwas was der
computer machen kann und so echte
anwendungen führt geht es nicht trotzdem
eine ähnlichkeit mit dem gehirn insofern
als wenn ich das richtig verstehe ja der
entscheidende mechanismus eigentlich
immer wieder der rückkehr der
rückkopplung auf einer weiteren ebene
ist also ich schaue mir das ergebnis an
koppel das rück mit einem mit einem
sollwert korrigiere korrigiere das und
das passiert das passiert laufen halten
sie es für für unwahrscheinlich ist man
sagt im grunde genommen entsteht so was
wie intelligenz vielleicht auch
bewusstsein reden darüber bewusst sein
einfach durch rückkopplung phänomen für
viel wissen für was man sich heute
kriegt sich intelligenz verwendet wird
ist die neurobiologie eine inspiration
die neurobiologie wird nicht kopiert
nicht direkt umgesetzt
dann versuchten jetzt nicht so verstehen
wir in einzelnen euro möglich
funktioniert wie wir alle zusammen
geschaltet ist und und dann das auf den
computer zu übertragen sondern der
computer lernt mit bestimmten
algorithmen und zum beispiel das was
gezeigt wurde in dem video ein computer
der go besser als ein mensch spielen
kann das programm lernt und dadurch dass
der computer gegen den computer spielten
ja spielt millionen von partien über
nacht und dann verändert seine parameter
verändert seit ich hoch kopplung aber da
gibt es kein mensch noch der den
computer trainiert der computer
trainiert sich selber und deswegen habe
ich den eindruck dass manchmal in der
die diskussion in der öffentlichen
diskussion gesagt dass neurobiologie und
günstig hinterlegt werden
ich habe ja eher der eindruck dass heute
neurobiologie wir können da seine
inspiration aber nicht irgendwann wieder
das gemacht wird können sie ganz kurz
manchmal sagen wie viele leute in ihrem
bereich also informatik
computerwissenschaften usw
wirklich daran arbeiten sozusagen gehirn
nachzubauen und wie viele andere leute
sagen ist mir völlig egal hauptsache das
ding funktioniert und hat einen
richtigen auto ja das kann ich sehr gut
weil ich bin häufig sowieso wir sind bei
google facebook apple bei amazon
ich habe viele kollegen da und kann ich
ihnen sagen diese über die größte labor
auf der welt sind
da gibt es einen bruchteil von personen
wirklich kann man fast mit der hand
abzählen
die neue novelle betreiben die anderen
arbeiter nicht massiven daten wasser und
die interessieren sich verlieren wenn
das meine ich
es ist sehr wichtig dass wir ihn
verstehen und ich selber interessiere
mich sehr dafür aber man muss nicht
daran denken dass ich heute für computer
die mit karriere widmen arbeiten das
selber tun als das gleiche und will da
gar nicht widersprechen aber das heißt
ja nicht dass man zu ähnlichen lösungen
kommt also ich glaub worauf sie
anspielen ist dass wir ja auch durch ein
einmaliges tun durch autobiografische
erfahrungen massiv unser verhalten
ändern können das wäre also nicht viele
wiederholungen keine mustererkennung
sondern ist ein wirklich einmalige
ereignisse die prägend für unser leben
sind das ist glaube ich ganz anders
organisiert als das beim gelungenen als
das bei der key der fall ist aber unsere
gewohnheiten unsere routinen auch das
was wir motorisch gelernt haben sind
musste erkennungs prozesse die in
bestimmten gehirnstrukturen dadurch
vonstatten gehen dass auch hier soll
werte erreicht werden müssen
das ist hier neurotransmitter systeme
gibt die dafür sorgen dass bestimmte
erwartungshaltung gemessen werden ob die
erreicht werden oder nicht und dann eben
auch in der rückwärts schleife wieder
eingepflegt werden um eben das nächste
verhalten noch besser anzupassen ich zum
beispiel sport mache wie man muskeln
aktiviert wird ob das wirklich optimal
geschieht
das brauche ich auch viele durchläufe
was es beim menschen noch eine rolle
spielt ist dass wir nicht nur diese
vielen durchläufe brauchen um das muster
eines aufschlages zum beispiel perfekt
zu können sondern wir versuchen auch
immer zu berechnen was als nächstes
passiert und messen daneben ob das was
den effekt den das hat mit dem
übereinstimmt was der gemessen haben
aber das sind schon auch algorithmen die
glaube ich zumindest ähnlich sind die
ihr die auch die ki weit vorangebracht
hat
also ja auch viele philosophen immer
gedacht es steigt aus den sinnen etwas
auf und wird immer abstrakter aber das
neue verständnis dass wir heute haben
ist das was aufsteigt in der hierarchie
vorhersage fehler sind also das sehr
vereinfacht gesagt so ein modell von
oben auf den input drauf drückt und
versucht den vorherzusagen so gut es
geht und das einzige was wir merken ist
wenn solche vorhersagen nicht stimmen
und uns wir können halt viele sachen
sehr schnell lernen im gegensatz zu
solchen künstlichen systemen weil wir
millionen von jahren von evolution auch
im rücken haben also in uns sind
sozusagen vorhersagen darüber was in
unserer umwelt geht die sind gewonnen
auch in der struktur unseres körpers
nicht nur unseres gehirns und was ich
daran so faszinierend finde ist dass
nicht nur die struktur unserer körper in
unserer gehirne sondern alle unsere
geistigen eigenschaften aus einem
prozess kommen der kein ziel und keine
richtung hatte die evolution und was
sich da ebenso teilweise gehört habe so
ein bisschen so was mit den miteinander
kämpfenden systemen die kognitive
fähigkeiten selbst organisieren haben
wir ja heute in der ki auch dass da
sozusagen evolutionäre strukturen
entstehen wo nicht mehr top down was
rein gegeben wird dass auch systeme
entstehen können die ihre konstrukteure
überraschen mit neuen eigenschaften aber
ich setze werde der unterschied aus
folgenden das bild häufig über die
singularität gesprochen über diese
kompetenz von eur gelungen
und digitalisierung und es gibt menschen
die dort zwei die wir daran dass sie
eines tages ihr gehirn in den computer
downloaden und sie leben für immer
weiter in den computer und ich denke das
ist einfach quatsch menschliche
intelligenz ist körperlichkeit ist die
biologie so dass wir uns bloß vielleicht
algorithmen vielleicht
informationsverarbeitung aber beide
sachen umgehen zusammen
wir können nicht an menschliche
intelligenz weil dann denken ohne
weiteres sucht und und im computer
können wir wirklich not aufgegangen wir
können den wirklichen oder algorithmen
und informationsverarbeitung kann los
gekoppelt von der computer und der
computer und ich glaube das ist der
große unterschied zwischen menschlichen
glücklichen bürger um gibt es denn ein
roboter also irgendwie spielt der körper
doch eine rolle für die intelligenz oder
die robotik doch nicht entstanden wenn
man die menschliche installieren
natürlich und die robotik hat der sinn
dass wir agieren oder wir möchten über
unsere systeme in der welt agieren wenn
man möchte die welt modifizieren und
deswegen gibt es auch keinesfalls ein
taxi ist und nicht nach hause fährt aber
ich denke dass das diese idee dass sie
käuflich zu lassen ist dass beides
kombiniert falsch ist und petrus hat das
denke ich so richtig gesagt dass seine
bücher hat gesagt die menschen haben
angst dass die computer intelligent
werden und die um die intelligent werden
und die welt wird nehmen und die
computer sind dumm und ich haben die
welt schon längst übernommen
[Gelächter]
wenn ich wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe dann spielt doch eine ganz große
rolle
das haben sie ja eben erläutert dass das
arbeitsgedächtnis also das was ich im
moment präsent habe das ist wie wir
gelernt haben also einmal die die die
die sinneswahrnehmung also meine
umgebung mich selber meinen zustand
wahrzunehmen
das ist haben wir haben wir gelernt eine
projektion also andere philosophen
würden wahrscheinlich sagen eine fiktion
von dem was ich in erwartung von dem was
ich in zukunft machen würde wie wie
abhängig ist denn bewusstsein von diesem
arbeitsspeicher ist dass das so ist ist
das selbe ist es ist sicher nicht allein
davon abhängig war man würde dann ganz
schnell auch wieder eine absurde
situation geraten als man das gefühl
hätte dass in diesem arbeitsgedächtnis
kinobesucher sitzt der das gehirn
beobachtet das funktioniert
offensichtlich nicht weil wir dann ganz
schnell bei dem problem einer russischen
puppen sind weil er beobachtet dann
gehen also so einfach ist es nicht plus
wir können auch durchaus in einzelnen
sinneskanäle zum beispiel beim hören von
musik kann die alles andere dominieren
und man kann musik eigentlich nur
verstehen wenn man ja auch
zwischenspeichert welche töne vorher
gewesen sind sonst könnte ich den
rhythmus und die melodie nicht als liga
vergleichen auch da spielt das
arbeitsgedächtnis wieder eine große
rolle als als kurzzeit speichert er auch
an verschiedenen stellen im gehirn
geschehen kann warum es so intensiv
diskutiert wird ist dass man sich
irgendwie fragt dass wir selber wenn wir
glauben dass wir autonom agieren ja
nicht mehrere ich personen erleben die
das machen sondern eine sondern in der
regel es sei denn man sagt dann wir sind
krank und leide unter psychischen
problemen und die die frage sehen wie
das gehirn dass das herstellt und da
spielt das arbeitsgedächtnis ich eine
ganz entscheidende rolle weil ich dafür
irgendeine art von protokoll brauche was
ich vorher gemacht habe was sich am
rhein geht welcher welche algorithmen im
gehirn selber aktiv waren aber es kann
das auch nicht alleine gewesen sein weil
wenn ich in dieses arbeitsgedächtnis
rhein gucken würde würde ich dann nichts
finden da wurde nicht gekleckert sondern
geklotzt vollmundig wurde 2013 das human
brain project angekündigt ein auf zehn
jahre angelegt
das eu flaggschiffprojekt der
interdisziplinären forschung für das die
eu rund 1,2 milliarden euro ausgeben
wird das fernziel ist es ein
computermodell des gesamten gehirns zu
erstellen
natürlich gab es vorläufer dieses
projekt ist das so genannte blue brain
project das versuchte teile eines raten
gehirns zu simulieren man beschränke
sich dabei auf einen kleinen teil der
großhirnrinde und ein gebiet von gerade
mal zwei mal 0,5 millimeter
all das ehrlich gesagt mit mäßigem
erfolg und gemessen am gesamt gehirn in
einen extrem kleinen ausschnitt jetzt
erhofft man sich vom großprojekt human
brain project nicht nur das gesamte
menschliche gehirn als modell simulieren
zu können sondern auch neuartige
verfahren zu entdecken um computer
besser bauen zu können nur gehört man
hat man in letzter zeit wenig davon
frage also wie ist der aktuelle stand
der dinge
das ist derzeit die hauptarbeit beim
human brain project ein menschliches
gehirn wird in sieben bis 8000
hauchdünne scheiben geschnitten
ziel ist die architektur von 86
milliarden nervenzellen in einem
dreidimensionalen gehirn modell sichtbar
zu machen
jeder schritt muss deshalb extrem
sorgfältig behandelt und auf glasplatten
fixiert werden
die hirn schnitte werden eingescannt und
miteinander verrechnet ein schnittbild
beansprucht 15 gigabyte um ein
menschliches gehirn komplett zu
digitalisieren benötigen die
wissenschaftler ein jahr
insgesamt werden zehn spender gehirne
digitalisiert und für den gehirn aclasta
abgeglichen
letztendlich ist so ein gehirn atlas
etwas ganz ähnliches wie eine google map
man möchte eine sehr hoch aufgelöste
karte haben mit möglichst vielen
informationen über eine bestimmte region
um dann eben besser zu verstehen wie man
wie diese hirnregion funktioniert in
einem sogenannten referenz gehirn können
wissenschaftler aus aller welt ihre
forschungen zu einzelnen gehirnregionen
zusammentragen die dann ebenfalls in den
gehirn atlas einfließen um die komplexen
verbindung strukturen zwischen den
einzelnen regionen und die grundlegenden
molekularen prozesse zu verstehen
brauchen die wissenschaftler jedoch
völlig neue computersysteme
sie müssen gewaltige datenmengen
verarbeiten und die vielen wechseln
wirkenden ebenen des gehirns beschreiben
das beflügelt einerseits die
neurowissenschaften weil sie dann eben
dinge miteinander verknüpfen können die
vorher einfach nebeneinander gestanden
haben und andererseits ist es natürlich
auch eine treibende kraft für die
technologie und computer entwickeln
entwicklung die dann also sogenannte use
cases also irgendwelche besonderen
wissenschaftlichen fragestellung haben
die ihnen helfen den technologie
entwicklern computerwissenschaftler neue
systeme hervorzubringen die eben dann
noch mal schneller sind oder eine
bestimmte art der verarbeitung besonders
effizient durchführen können das ist so
eine win win situation für beide seiten
ein beispiel für die
informationsverarbeitung von
nervenzellen haben die
neurowissenschaftler theoretische
modelle entwickelt computerspezialisten
haben diese modelle dann in
mathematische formeln gegossen und eine
neue hardware konstruiert die neuronen
chips und den euro machen computer und
versucht die elektrische aktivität einer
nervenzelle zu simulieren so eine
nervenzelle hat eine aktivität die so
ein picafort bringt und wenn dieser pick
da ist dann wird die information zur
nächsten nervenzelle weitergetragen und
diese analogen neuerung morphen computer
die versuchen genau das nachzubilden
also nicht mit neuen und einzeln zu
arbeiten sondern mit solchen
komplizierteren physiologischen signalen
und es zeigt sich dass eben für
bestimmte lernprozesse das sehr viel
effizienter es um informationen weiter
zu verarbeiten als wir das mit dem
klassischen binären system sehen diese
technologie des maschinellen lernens
wird schon in verschiedenen systemen
angewendet der bisher größte neuerung
auch für computer wurde letztes jahr
nach zwanzigjähriger entwicklung in
manchester fertiggestellt er soll in
zukunft die leistung von einer milliarde
neuronen in echtzeit simulieren
das ist etwa ein prozent des
menschlichen gehirns mit den
erkenntnissen aus der computer
architektur und robotik wollen die
neurologen dann wieder rückschlüsse auf
die funktionsweise des gehirns ziehen
wir sehen auf der anderen seite
natürlich dass diese künstlichen
neuronalen netzen meistens eine sehr
enge einsatzmöglichkeit haben und das
ist im moment noch einen riesen
unterschied zum menschlichen gehirn was
ja ganz ganz unterschiedliche dinge
lernen kann kombinieren kann diese
grosse flexibilität und auch dieses
lernen beim ersten mal
das ist etwas was die maschinen noch
nicht so gut können also ein kind
braucht man nicht 1000 katzen zu zeigen
damit das kind beim 1000 ersten mal eine
katze erkennt was für einen
supercomputer muss man bauen damit so
etwas wie bewusstsein entsteht da muss
auf jeden fall für viele verschiedene
aufgaben unterschiedliche computer
systeme integrieren können
aber vielleicht findet das human brain
project nur heraus dass man das
bewusstsein gar nicht mit algorithmen
beschreiben kann
sie müssen wir mal helfen wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe dann baue ich
mit hilfe der anatomie unserer realen
gehirne die eine mischung aus in dem
fall zehn einzel gehirn sind so eine art
landkarte so jetzt habe ich eine
landkarte meines gehirns die ist aber
tot da fährt keiner drauf also bildhaft
gesprochen da ist kein da fährt kein
auto da ist kein impuls was weiß ich
denn jetzt wenn ich die landkarte habe
weiß ich da überhaupt irgendwas eine
ganze masse wird man kann versuchen zum
beispiel die die ganzen struktur
beziehungen zwischen verschiedenen
gehirnarealen gegen die gewichtung
zwischen den gehirnarealen auch den
modularen aufbau sie haben eben sehr
stark für den modularen aufbau plädiert
das kann man jetzt experimentell
überprüfen finde ich vergleichbare
strukturen in vergleichbarer größe
sozusagen nicht krieg nicht rein
kristallin aber zumindest modularen
nebeneinander welche gehirnareale können
überhaupt mit welchen gehirnarealen
reden da stellt man zum beispiel fest
dass die gehirnareale die die gefühle
anderer menschen repräsentieren gar
nicht so stark mit unseren reihen
analytisch rationalen denkweisen
kommunizieren das sind zum beispiel so
erkenntnisse die man aus diesen
prozessen gewinnen kann nun und ich
denke darin begründet sich auch ihre
frage
wenn ich die funktion eines organs
beschreiben will brauche ich natürlich
mehr als die struktur das würde man bei
einer niere und beim herz und auch
benötigen das ist beim gehirn nicht
anders aber dadurch dass das gehirn ihn
sich schon eine so ungeheure
strukturelle komplexität hat sind eben
da die forscher der meinung wenn sie die
aufschlüsselung können dass man schon
mal einen ganzen großen teil des puzzles
sozusagen mit erforscht und und erledigt
hat ich würde sagen der sprecher der
informatik wo ich selber man kennt sich
halt und die verschaltung aber nicht die
algorithmen
ihr habt die drauf laufen um zu
verstehen welche von
informationsverarbeitung im gehirn
geschieht um möglicherweise machen die
doch das aus was wir bewusstsein nennen
das ist der prozess das laufend der
algorithmen die physikalische
realisierung des prozesses das ja auch
ein kandidat dafür
wie würde das dann also dass eine asyl
na ja wir haben die hardware okay dann
haben wir die die algorithmen die
sozusagen den verkehr zwischen den
einzelnen modulen einheiten steuern und
das was wie sie vorschlagen wir jetzt zu
sagen dieses gesamtgeschehen ist das was
bewusstsein ist das geschehen dass
dadurch auf mehreren ebenen beschrieben
wird dass die dynamik in der zeit die
auch in sich verschachtelte sich
verwickelt ist
die ist irgendwie kritisch denke ich
aber ich bin da natürlich kein fachmann
also das ist ein ganz schöner gedanke
was man beim gehirn allerdings noch
berücksichtigen muss ist dass ich so
ganz einfach hardware und software nicht
voneinander trennen lassen was man zum
beispiel merkt wenn gehirne lernen
werden die strukturen wie nervenzellen
miteinander verbunden sind verändert sie
haben ja eben auf die unterschiede
hingewiesen ich glaube das ist auch noch
etwas wasser auf ihre mühlen das ist
auch noch ein großer unterschied wenn
wir lernen wird mich eine festplatte
gefühlt sondern das gehirn verändert
seine verschaltung eigenschaften im
nehmen nach einem leeren ereignis die
welt anders wahr wir strukturieren sie
anders wir haben andere
erwartungshaltungen die prozesse in
unserem gehirn also die algorithmen die
im gehirn ablaufen sind anders und auch
die motorik verändert sich und das ist
natürlich ein großer baulicher
unterschied der gleichzeitig aber auch
rechtfertigt warum es so wichtig ist die
strukturen auch mit zu analysieren die
diesem organ zugrunde liegen
dieses dieses umschalten des gehirns
oder der der prozesse die ja zum
beispiel durch lernen ein treffen kann
die kann ja unter umständen sehr
plötzlich passieren also das was man in
der physik phasenübergang hält er
plötzlich verändert sich die struktur
des gehirns das darf man sich ja nicht
so vorstellen als ob da ganz viele
einzelne schritte zu notwendig sind und
dann irgendwann mal schaltet das gehirn
um wenn man das wenn man das ernst nimmt
dann heißt das doch wir haben noch nicht
verstanden wie das gehirn auf einer
höheren ebene also immer höheren
dimensional i tät diese prozesse steuert
und regelt
weil sonst wäre das ja gar nicht so
möglich wie es passiert ich weiß nicht
ob das verständlich war jetzt ja ich
will das keiner weiß heute wie
bewusstsein stimmt dass das kann man so
sagen tja was wir eigentlich hier in
welche neutronen dass sie in welche
verschaltungen deswegen das connector
wird untersucht es wird mit mit rücken
und mit der firma geguckt welche real
ich hier und schaltete sich ein wenn
etwas verbreitert wird aber wie wir
bewusstsein entsteht das weiß keiner
versorgen also ein bisschen geschmunzelt
ich bin kein fachmann es gibt keine
fachmänner für bewusstsein
eigentlich ist ja vieles oft wenn er
dazu berufen uns so beleuchten ende also
wir haben das wort erfunden
dafür kriegen wir geld das mir ein
bisschen sorgen macht es das folgend ich
habe vor 23 jahren ja mal die erste
wissenschaftliche gesellschaft zur
erforschung des bewusstseins die
association for scientific sessions mit
gegründet da sind die 600 hardcore leute
drin auf der welt und jetzt ist es auf
einmal so dass es genau zu kia gibt in
melbourne also ganz hoch angesehene
kollegen rita kann in tokio ist an der
hin- und seine gruppe in paris oder
michael graziano in princeton alles
führende anerkannte bewusstseins
forscher die sagen gewonnen künstliches
bewusstsein machen und wir machen das so
wie wir das hinkriegen und da bin ich
eben aus ethischen gründen strikt
dagegen ich finde wir sollten erstmal so
ein moratorium
synthetische phänomenologie haben für
mindestens 30 jahre und nicht riskieren
auch nur in die nähe zu kommen
es ist nämlich so man muss keine theorie
von etwas haben um sie zu locken
entstehen wir hatten noch keine theorie
von gravitation und sind trotzdem äpfel
von bäumen gefallen und es ist auch
nicht so dass wenn gros also sozusagen
von der handlungs theorie von der
risikobewertung her wenn der schaden der
in der zukunft ist vielleicht eine
geringe eintretens wahrscheinlichkeit
hat aber sehr groß sein könnte dass es
nicht jetzt schon wichtig wäre
ressourcen da rein zu tun genau zu
überlegen auch forschungs ethisch was
wir da tun und was wir da nicht tun
ein weiteres wichtiges stichwort ist s&t
mische bescheidenheit man sieht das ja
die fachleute in dem gebiet haben ganz
verschiedene main und es gibt leute die
sagen wir werden bewusst seinen 20
jahren haben auf maschinen wir machen
das jetzt
es gibt genauso gute fachleute die sagen
das wird es niemals geben und in so
einer situation ist es immer gut nicht
zu viel auf seine eigene meinung zu
geben und ganz vorsichtig zu sein
in der wissenschaftsgeschichte sind
nämlich manchmal dinge auch schneller
passiert als die fachleute selbst
gedacht haben enrico fermi zum beispiel
hat sechs monate vor der kernspaltung
noch gesagt das kriegen wir entweder nie
hin oder in 50 jahren
und da gibt es mehrere beispiele dass
die fachleute selbst gesagt haben auch
das kommt noch lange nicht und dann sind
unerwartet verschiedene sachen
zusammengekommen und dann war die
entdeckung doch plötzlich da und ich bin
dafür
also aus ethischen gründen weil wir auch
künstliches leiden erzeugen könnten wenn
wir das thema mit bewusstsein wenn wir
künstliches bewusstsein erzeugen
synthetische phänomenologie dass wir da
ganz ganz vorsichtig bin ich bin ganz
bescheiden und ich kann dir aber
beruhigen
wir sind so weit entfernt in der technik
künstlich ist bewusstsein erzeugen so
können dass wir in den nächsten 30
jahren
hat enrico fermi auch gesagt nein das
ist etwas anderes die physik ist etwas
hat es war nicht nur die usa die
versucht haben eine atommacht mit so
auch noch andere länder und die wahlen
kurzweil werden ich denke dass ich denke
das was angesprochen wird die frage wer
tätig ist sehr wichtig aber im sinne der
anwendung im zehnerfeld programmierer
und entwickler
ich glaube das ist wichtige ethische
probleme zum beispiel bei der einsetzung
von robotischen waffen gibt es gibt auch
das problem
sollen wir die ganze manufaktur
automatisierung dann gibt keine
arbeitsplätze aber das sind ja die
üblichen probleme die ich mit jeder
technologie habe also darf ich sie für
den krieg einsetzen dürfen sie anderen
menschen schädigen dürfen sie
arbeitsplätze weg in das sind ja die
üblichen probleme ist wieder nicht
energie also ich bin ja das ist ihr
problem ist am rosenmontag gerade aus
brüssel wieder zurückgekommen aus dieser
high level group for artificial
intelligence also autonome tödliche
waffen systeme schaffen schon neue
qualitäten entscheide also wie sie
senken zum beispiel die kriegs
eintrittsschwelle und wenn wir jetzt
noch ein wettrüsten oberhalb von
kernwaffen bekommen und es sieht so aus
dann entstehen historisch auch ganz neue
qualitäten also wenn man schwärme von
drohnen los und sicher weiß keiner von
uns stirbt dann verhält man sich ganz
anders im krieg als man sich bis jetzt
verhalten hat und da gibt es viele
dieser probleme das sicher ganz wichtige
ethische fragen auf einer anderen ebene
sehe ich die auch auf mehr auf der
biomedizinischen ebene hinsichtlich der
versprechungen die sie gemacht werden
dass wenn man nämlich sagt man könnte
gehirn auf eine festplatte sozusagen
downloaden
also darauf ab schreiben dass man so in
dem menschen quasi im grunde doch
verspricht sie können im grunde im
geiste zumindest ewig leben oder hasst
man durch die böning krankheiten viel
besser behandeln kann und da muss man
sagen da würde ich mir wünschen ähnlich
wie auch in anderen bereichen im
medizinischen forschung immer auch klar
zu machen wie groß die probleme sind die
man dabei überwinden kann
wir würden uns sicher müssen sich alle
einig es wäre toll für bestimmte
krankheiten könnte man neben der
ärztlichen expertise nachdem von deep
machine learning benutzen
aber da muss man auch sagen wir ganz
viele dieser prozesse ist man ganz ganz
weit weg von einer realisierung und
andere wären
möglicherweise gar nicht realisieren
lassen weil man hier etwas verspricht
über eine struktur nämlich dem gehirn
was man in seinen grundfesten noch gar
nicht verstanden hatte ich kann gar
nicht downloaden weil es keine
festplatte es gibt noch eine andere
haben nur noch 20 sekunden leider und
robotische roboter in der pflege
wie soll mein gedanke darf ich werd lang
warum wir uns so sehr für das problem
des bewusstseins interessieren hängt
auch mit sterblichkeit von florian dung
zusammen
wir sind biologische überlebens
maschinen die unglücklicherweise wissen
dass sie sterben werden und darum
interessiert uns das problem intelligent
wenn sie gerade das müssen aber das war
es leider schon mit thema 50 bewusstsein
vielen dank natürlich bleibt große
skepsis habe man erlebt zurecht trotz
aller erfolge aber skeptiker sollten
vielleicht nicht zu früh frohlocken das
argument dafür lieferte 1890 der
philosoph und mitbegründer der modernen
psychologie wohl nehmen james und zwar
macht er darauf aufmerksam dass ein
grundprinzip der evolution in allen
bereichen kontinuität ist deshalb
schreibt er
sollten wir uns ernsthaft mit jeder
möglichkeit auseinandersetzen das
heraufdämmern des bewusstseins in einer
weise zu erklären
die ist nicht als den plötzlichen
einbruch einer völlig neuen bis dahin
nicht existenten kraft erscheint ist
also james meinte dass auch künstliches
bewusstsein sowie unser eigenes ohne
zaubertrick entstehen könnte weil alles
eine kontinuierliche
entwicklungsgeschichte hat frau wird
damit bewusst sein denn dann auf
ähnliche weise möglich wie wir menschen
die sich irgendwann mal auszahlen und
quallen tieren entwickelt haben
allerdings hat die evolution dafür
einige hundert millionen jahre gebraucht
wo in diesem sinne können sie gut
schlafen ohne mit künstlichem
bewusstsein und synthetischer dummheit
rechnen zu müssen und tschüss